je m'appelle Claude François vous verrez
un jour je ferai un disque je ne veux
pas d'un fils seulement
vous croyez vraiment que c'est ce genre
de musique que les jeunes de votre
trajet coûte je te jure il a un truc
avec le public
n'est pas le seul il y a beaucoup de coq
dans la basse-cour
je veux l'adapter en français si moi je
chante ça
je te fais un disque d'or
ça vous présenter Paul Lederman
j'aimerais qu'il soit votre sérieux je
vais vous étonner
vraiment tu étais extraordinaire Cloclo
et c'est Claudette je ne peux plus rien
y faire
rien dans 6 mois tu es fini j'ai envie
de savoir
tu contrôles tout tout le monde ça va
s'arrêter quand ton système
je resterai avec moi
la journée
je vais jouer